hey everyone welcome to simply learns
youtube channel in this session we will
be discussing about the top java
projects to learn in 2022 but before we
begin let me tell you guys that we have
daily updates on multiple technologies
so if you're a tech geek in a continuous
hunt for latest technological trends
then consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply done now without further ado
let's get started with today's topic
that is the top java projects so in our
agenda
we will get started with the top 10
project ideas for 2022 followed by that
we will learn the core java projects so
we will go through some exciting core
java projects for example
online banking system and atm java
project and many more followed by the
core java projects we will create an
advanced java project along with spring
framework so i hope i made myself clear
with the agenda now without further ado
let's get started with java projects for
2022
over to our experts
the top 10 java project ideas
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system
so this particular project motto is to
deal with the courier management system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
any one which has a good support for
java the most preferable one would be
the eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flipkart so
mato etc are basically planned and have
reached greater heights today this kind
of project on your resume could make a
huge difference and who knows tomorrow
you might even get into one of those
companies and start working on their
projects or build a company of your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system
now thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cast their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate as their own choice
with an unmatchable ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show
online voting functionality followed by
the abstract we will get into the
technicality of this particular project
so the first phase of this particular
project has the admin phase where the
admin has the right to manage the
candidates manage the voters and their
profiles and passwords and finally
election results followed by the admin
we have the voter or the user of this
particular application the voter or the
user gets to register himself or herself
into the application followed by that he
can use the login and logout options and
next we have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management named as the
corporate medicare management this
e-health care management system is a
web-based project developed in java the
main aim of this particular project is
to provide effective management of data
related to staff and patients in
hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end and java
as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka
and oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-healthcare management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects so new
features and modules can be easily
integrated into the system in the future
followed by the e-health care management
system we have a new normal online
banking not interesting and arousing for
a normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a
rollercoaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop the customers can access
bank's website for viewing their account
details and perform the transactions on
account as per the requirement bank
employees can log in and add customer
and account information to perform
transactions with internet banking with
internet banking the brick and mortar
structure of the traditional bank gets
converted into a click and portal mode
thereby giving the concept of virtual
banking a real shape thus today's
banking is no longer confined to
branches e-banking facilities banking
transactions by
customers round the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular project are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts log in and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account read
raman from the selected account transfer
the amount from one account to another
close the account so the software
requirements for this particular project
are java programming language and and
javascript for scripting language and
oracle for database and tomcat for
server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project online exams are normal for us
nowadays but this is totally limited to
high-end exams like cet gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios
many schools and colleges have now
turned towards the online education
system and are looking forward to
hosting online exams for student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students so the students
can login update their profile and
password select answers for the mcqs
write answers to questions and finally
closing the session and log out this
particular project can be made a grand
success by making use of simple java
servlets and java programming languages
and server like apache tomcat followed
by the online examinations we have the
smart city smart city java project can
be a web-based software developed to
store the details of a particular city
the main purpose of the project is to
help tourists and other visitors to a
city by providing information about
hotels transportation facilities air
ticket booking shopping details city
news etc the smart city java project
serves the visitors as a guide of the
city and hence the project is called as
city guide project in java using this
project the details of the city can be
accessed from anywhere at any time the
implementation of the city project
promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option
booking that option and payment window
finally the confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
design drones that can act like a corp
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or comps or
travel agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have
the bug tracking system
the back tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java program
and language for software companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution the system is
fully secured and authentication method
is adopted
to manage security it stores the old
debug reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting as the javascript and the
id for this particular project would be
eclipse with all the my eclipse plugins
and finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java a npr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing algorithms so
followed by vehicle recognition project
we have our last project which is the
speech recognition system
so speech recognizer converts audio to
text java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus a set
of supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener comment changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse so in
this session we are going to focus on a
particular project
and the project we are going to focus is
is about an atm application
so you might have interacted with
different atm stores in your cities
where you go in you insert your card you
enter your pin and then you can view the
balance you can withdraw some amount you
can also deposit some amount from the
atm
so we will try to look at it from that
perspective and and we will see what
kind of different
uh java and oops concepts we can use to
build such atm application
this is not a super versatile
application but this is just to give you
the idea of how to use
those oops concepts to build a simple or
a complex java application so let's
start from the options menu class
because that will give us the
understanding of what kind of
functionality i'm using
and here you will use that
i am using different concepts which i
have taught you so far in this
particular series
so for example we are using the
ioexception we are using the hashmap
class we are also using a scanner class
which is used to take input from the
command line so this option menu class
is extending the account class and i
will come to the account class in a
while but let's see what this option
menu class is doing
this particular class has uh it is using
a decimal format money format class
which is to denote what kind of
format of money you have
then we have a hash map which is storing
the couple of
records of account number to pin mapping
so we create an map and inside the get
login method
we add couple of entries to the map
here the first entry the first integer
is pointing to the customer number
and the second integer is pointing to
the pin of the account of this
particular customer number
so
if we call the get login method this
method will insert the data
after that it will ask the customer to
enter the customer number which has to
be one of these two
if you provide any other value then
there should be a logic in the
application to reject the input
so whatever customer number the customer
inputs we pass that inside this
particular method called set customer
number
again i will come back to that
and once you have provided a valid
customer number then this method is
going to ask you to enter a pin number
and remember i told you this is the
customer number to the pin number
mapping so whatever customer number you
select from here
you will be providing the corresponding
pin number and again if you provide an
invalid pin number you will get an error
so that will all happen inside this try
block and
if you enter any invalid characters in
the pin number or the atm
customer number then you will get an
exception which i am writing inside the
catch block
this is all what we have seen so far
after the successful enter of the
customer number and the pin number i
fetch those values from these two
methods again i will talk about what
these methods are doing and again i'm
doing some basic validation checks but
things get interesting in this method
so what we covered so far was the get
login method let me close this method
here
so we covered the get login method the
second method which is defined in this
particular class is the account type
so here that we will ask the once the
customer has provided the customer
number and the pin number we will ask
the customer to provide the account type
this application supports two different
account types which are checking account
or a savings account
so whatever so the customer has to
choose one of them again we will be
taking the input from the command line
using the scanner class
and then i'm using a switch case if the
customer entered one then i will execute
some code for the checking account which
is defined here in the case 1
and if the customer enter 2 then the
case 2 will be executed
and if the if it enters 3 then i will
exit the application by just printing
assist out
so here i'm using the switch case
construct to provide different options
to the customer
there's also a default case specified
here which says invalid choice
so this is what is happening in the get
account type method
the next method is if the customer has
used the option one
then we call the get checking method
so let's go to the get checking method
which is the next method which is
defined in this particular class so if
the customer has selected a checking
account then we provide the following
functionality to the customer
which is the customer can view the
balance
customer can withdraw the funds
customer can deposit the funds to the
checking account or they can just exit
the application
and again i'm using a switch case here
based on the customer types 1 2 3 or 4
the corresponding case block will be
executed for example if the customer
wants to view the balance then this
block will get executed and i call the
get account type method
if the customer selects the
to as the withdraw fund then get
checkings with withdraw input method
gets called
and then get account type gets called
similarly if the customer enters three
then we deposit the fund and for that
also i have defined a method i will go
to the definition of these methods as we
go along but right now we are just
building the framework so the get
checking deposit input method will be
called whenever the customer selects the
option three
and for option four we just exit the
application
so this is what is happening in the get
checking method
now if from the account selection if the
customer selected second option which
was savings account then we were calling
get saving method
so this is where the get saving method
is defined
and again it is following the exact same
format as we saw in the get checking
method
where we present the following options
like viewing balance withdrawing the
funds and depositing the funds in the
savings account
and i have some methods defined here for
example get saving withdraw input
get saving deposit input
so we define the switch case here based
on the customer's choices here
and that is what is happening in the get
saving method so let me close this
method as well and that's all what is
defined inside the option menu class
so we ask the customer to enter the
customer number the pin number from this
get login method
then based on
that we provide the customer the options
to choose the account type whether they
can choose the savings account or the
checking account
and based on that whatever account type
they use we call the get checking or get
saving method and inside this method we
provide the customer the other options
to either withdraw the money deposit the
money or view the balance
that is what is happening inside this
option menu class
now let's go to the account class and
all the methods which we saw here will
be provided a definition in the account
class
you also see this option menu is
extending the accounts class so an
inheritance concept is being used here
let's go to the account class now
so this is the account class where i
have defined some private member
variables like customer number so now
you will be familiar with the customer
number pin number which i just described
and also with the checking balance and
the savings balance
you can also divide this account class
into two child classes where you have a
savings account class and a checking
account class
but for simplicity i've kept it to one
class
i'm initializing a scanner input which
will be used at multiple places and then
i have the setters and getters for these
four
member variables so you see set customer
number get customer number
if you remember this set customer number
was called in the option menu class if i
go back to the get login
once we ask the customer to enter the
customer number
we call the set customer number which
gets called here
similarly
we call the set pin number
which gets called here
similarly once we have said that we then
we were fetching the values using the
get customer number and the get pin
number
and that has that is also defined here
in terms of the getters
get pin number and get customer number
similarly we also have the getters for
the checking balance and the saving
balance
member variables
we do not have the setters for them
because they are not technically setters
but we have to calculate the balance
it's not a simple setter where you can
just return the value
so now let's look at some of the
business functions of the account class
how do you deposit how do you view the
balance how do you withdraw the balance
etc
so you see these two methods
which are specifically when the customer
is trying to withdraw the money from
their account
and these methods are basically called
internally by other methods so we will
come to that let's just understand that
we have two methods for calculating the
withdrawal amount or executing the
withdrawal transaction
for the checking account account and the
savings account
similarly i have two more methods here
which are calculating the depositing for
the checking account and calculating the
depositing for the savings account
and then we get the the bigger methods
which are using these calculation
methods so i define four calculation
methods so far calc checking withdraw
calc saving withdraw
calc checking deposit and calc saving
deposit basically withdrawing and
deposit for both of the classes
and then we have these business
functions called
get checking withdraw input
and get saving withdraw input
get checking deposit input and get
saving deposit input
so these getter methods are something
which were being called from the option
menu class if you remember
if you go back to the option menu class
and if you chose the checking account
you get these options and let's say you
chose option 2 which was withdraw funds
or option 3 which was deposit funds
then the corresponding methods which
were being called were get checking
withdraw input
and get checking deposit input
and this is the exact same method gets
checking withdraw input and
get checking deposit input
so if you see what is happening inside
this particular method is couple of
sysouts
then we
take the scanner input amount and we
convert that amount to the double
after that we check
if the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw is smaller than the checking
balance or not
and i'm running this condition to check
that
if the amount is smaller than the
checking balance
then we call the calc checking withdraw
method
which was defined right here
remember i told you that these four calc
methods will be used and this is how
they are used so here i'm actually
subtracting the value so whatever amount
the customer wants to withdraw
subtract that from the main balance and
then return the new main balance
that's what you do right if you have
thousand rupees and if you want to
withdraw 500 you subtract 500 from
thousand and then you send back the
remaining balance
so that is what is happening when we
call this method and then we print the
new checking account balance
that is what is happening in the get
checking withdraw input method
similarly if you chose option 3 which
was
depositing funds to the checking account
then get checking deposit input gets
called
and it is defined right here
get checking deposit input and here
instead of subtraction
we are doing the addition
so here i'm again doing a condition
check that the current balance plus the
new amount which has been supplied by
the customer from the command line
the total sum of it should be greater
than zero
what if the customer entered an amount
minus five thousand i should not allow
that
so that's the reason i'm putting this
condition in place and if the current
balance plus the new amount which is
supposed to be deposited to the account
the sum of it is greater than zero then
call the calc checking deposit method
and this is where the calc checking
deposit method is present and where i'm
just doing present balance plus the new
amount and returning the new balance
that's all which is being done here
and you will see exactly similar logic
running for the
savings account as well if you look at
the get saving withdraw input which is
used to withdraw money from the savings
account so i take the input from the
command line and i run a condition check
that the amount which the customer wants
to withdraw
should be less than the current saving
accounts balance
if yes then call calc saving withdraw
method
which is defined here whereby subtract
the
amount from the current balance and i
return the new balance
and similarly you will see the exact
same functionality in the get saving
deposit where we add the money instead
of subtracting the money
and this is all what is defined in the
account class
so we talked about the option menu class
we talked about the account class and
now we have the atm class which is the
entry point which basically initializes
the option menu class and calls the get
login method
remember get login was the first method
which asked you to provide the customer
number and then get login called the
method to choose the account type and
the account type methods then called the
method to choose the option to withdraw
deposit or exit
so now we have built a fair
understanding of what is happening in
this application so let's run this
application
so i just ran this application and let
me bring the console here
it's first asking for a customer number
so i will go to the option menu class
and i will
pick up one of the customer number which
i have hard coded here
so i will provide that customer number
and hit enter
then it asks me for the pin number so
remember you have to provide the correct
pin number corresponding to the customer
number
so i'm taking this pin number just
copying it and pasting it here
then
this whole code got executed
and then it called the get account type
and the get account type method provided
you with these options which you see
here on the screen so based on what you
select the case block will get executed
and let's say i want to go for a
checking account so i press 1
and i hit enter
once you select the checking account the
case 1 gets selected and it calls the
get checking method
and the get checking method again
provides you with another menu view
withdraw or deposit or exit
so let's say i want to deposit funds so
i press 3
and hit enter
it says the current balance is 0
and enter the amount you want to deposit
let's say i want to deposit 500
and i hit enter
you get the message saying the new
checking account balance is 500 and you
have successfully deposited the money
and that is what i did for the checking
account
now let's try to withdraw something from
the ticking account so you again get
back the same option because inside the
get checking method
we call the once we have successfully
done the business operation we again
call the account type method to display
the menu again to the user
so let's see again select the checking
account class
and this time i want to withdraw the
funds remember i've added 500 there
so let's say i want to withdraw so i
choose the option 2 as the choice
current balance is 500 and it's asking
me the amount you want to withdraw from
the checking account
so i enter let's say 100 and i hit enter
when i do that the new checking account
balance becomes 400 so the 100 got
subtracted from the 500 and the new
balance is shown to your screen
you can do exactly the same thing for
for the savings account as well
and let's also run a negative condition
so i again select the checking account
and i want to withdraw the funds i
choose the option two
current balance is 400 and i i would
like to withdraw a thousand
what happens
if you do that we get a message saying
balance cannot be negative and this is
coming from the calc checking method
which which is defined here so what is
happening that i wanted to withdraw the
funds from the checking account
and here get checking withdraw
input.called
here
this condition was checked so the
checking balance was
400
and the amount i wanted to withdraw was
thousand so 400 minus thousand is not
greater than equal to zero so it jumped
into the else block and it said balance
cannot be negative
so this is how you can also build some
error conditions in your code which are
mandatory and which should be built
otherwise your application will have a
lot of bugs
we can also exit the application so if
you just type three
and hit enter
you will exit from the application and
will again call the login method where
it will again ask you to enter the
customer number
so this is how you can run this
application and this is this was a
simple use case for you to show how you
can use the different object-oriented
concepts like classes objects methods
setters getters switch case etc to build
the application with the correct
business logic
and this is all i want to cover in this
particular session
and in the next session we are going to
have a look at another
interesting core java project just to
build our understanding more better
about the core java concept choose from
over 300 in demand skills and get access
to 1 000 plus hours of video content for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more let's get started with walking
through a core java project
using all the different oops concept we
have learned so far
so in this example
we are going to have a look at a
calculator application and this
calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition
subtraction
multiplication and division
so let's see how do we build that app
so in front of me right now is open the
main class
so i have a main app class here which
has a public static void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method
so if you go to the read input class
it has a simple static method here which
is the read method
and it is using the scanner class
if you remember i talked about the
scanner class which is used to take
inputs from the command line from the
user
so we initialize the scanner class and
we start taking the inputs and whatever
the user inputs in terms of the
expression let's say the user entered 4
plus 5 or whatever that whole expression
gets sent back into this
input line
as a string
and that comes back here in that input
expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression
in the numbers and the operators
basically an expression would be either
something like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say
let's say the user entered this
expression so this has either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically and
this split method is going to split the
numbers and operators into two different
string arrays and here i'm providing the
split expression that's split at every
time you encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array
which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4
5 3 and 2.
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split
or pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign
this multiply sign and this divide sign
hope you get the understanding that we
are just splitting the whole expression
into two different arrays
where first array is holding only the
numbers and no mathematical expressions
and second array is just holding the
mathematical operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i have created the string array i
just want to
store or convert these string arrays
into a queue
so i convert this
array into a list by calling the array
dot as list so this expression is going
to return a list
and then i'm going to
convert this normal list
into a linked list
and then going to store this linked list
into the queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this link list as a
queue
so i have an operators queue and i have
a numbers queue both of them have been
stored into a queue now
and then i'm using the poll method
if you remember the poll method of the
queue is used when you want to fetch the
first front element the head element of
the queue so whichever element is
sitting at the head of the queue will be
taken out the moment you call the
poll method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q
so in this case 4 will be fetched
here
in this variable and after that i run a
loop on the numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue
is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop
i do the exact same poll operation for
the operations queue so this operations
queue is holding all these mathematical
operations
like plus star and divide
so i'm going to pick the head of it so
in this case plus will be picked up and
will be stored in this variable called
opr and then i am going to run a switch
case on this opr
basically as i told you in this
particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition
subtraction multiplication and division
so i define a case for each of the
mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here
and for each case i'm initializing a
class if it's a plus sign then i'm
initializing the add class
if it's a minus sign then i'm
initializing the subtractors for
multiplication i have a class called
multiply and for division i have a class
called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing
so if i go to the add class first of all
it is implementing an interface called
operate
and this operate interface has just a
single method called get results
which is accepting a variable argument
array if you remember i told you that
you can also use a
array this is called a arg expression
this means that this numbers will be an
array of arbitrary length it can be a
one element array it can be a two
element array it can be a four element
array or whatever you supply
but it is still going to be a fixed
length array but the length is going to
be dependent upon how much argument you
supply to this particular method
so that is what this interface operate
is doing it just has one method declared
which is called get result which is
accepting an array of numbers so
if the add class is implementing the
operate interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and
the exact same kind of logic or similar
logic will be seen in other operate
classes so if i go to the subtract class
it runs the exact same operation but it
subtracts the values
if i go to the multiply class
it is also implementing the operate
interface and in the get result it is
just multiplying all the values
similarly in the divide class
it is also implementing the operator
interface and it is dividing all the
numbers one by one so it's doing pretty
much the same thing in terms of the
expression and the logic
the only difference is whether you are
using an add operation or a subtract or
multiply or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well
and let's go back to the main app now
now you also see that i've defined a
reference of operate here and each of
the switch case block
i'm assigning
the object type to this interface
reference so i'm using the concept of
dynamic binding which we talked about
when we talked about interfaces
that we can also do dynamic binding
where we can assign an object
to an interface type
and the object type will depend upon the
expression
so once we have filled that based on the
case
while
filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially
then we go to the next line outside the
switch case block which is to pick the
next
number from the queue
remember we already did one poll here
so
as for this example 4 was here in this
rest
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue
so we pick up 5 here
and then we call operate dot get result
now this get result will be called based
on the expression which was encountered
first in the queue
again looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operator type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked
and it is going to sum four and five
this rest is holding four right now
based on what i described here
numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically basically 5
here so 4 plus 5 gets evaluated here in
this case
and then it again goes back here and it
checks if the number q is
now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3 n2
left there so
again it does the operations dot pole
and it picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class
then coming here it will do a numbers
dot poll
and this time the numbers dot poll is
going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here
and then the current value of result
which is already 9 4 plus 5 was 9 the
current value of result will be updated
here so rest will be 9 here and num will
be 3 here and when you call
operate.getresult
the multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3
which will become 27.
it will again go back here to this
particular line and it will check again
if the numbers queue is now empty no it
is still not empty because we still have
one element left
then it pulls
the queue of the operations
where the expression divide is present
there which is the only element left in
this particular operations queue
and since we have the opr value as
divide
this case block gets called and the new
divide class gets initialized the divide
class basically gets initialized
and
we come here and we do numbers dot poll
now the last number which is available
in this queue is 2 which gets picked up
here
and then we again call operate.getresult
this time since the operate object refer
object operator reference type was of
divide class type so when we call
operate dot get result the divide
operation or the get result method of
the divide class
basically this method
will get invoked
and
it will
divide the current value of result which
was
4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27
so it is going to divide 27
by
2 which was the last value of the
numbers.poll it is going to execute 27
by 2 and whatever value it gets it is
going to store a value back into the
rest variable and then it is again going
to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers queue is
not empty but now the numbers q is empty
because 2 was the last element so it is
going to come out of the loop and it is
going to print the final result
that is how this whole program is
working
now let's try to see this in action and
we'll try to execute the exact same
expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3
divide 2
and if i now hit enter
i get the value as 13.5 which is exactly
what we ran through because 4 plus 5
will be evaluated first which will
result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly
so this is how this whole program is
running where we first take the inputs
and then we divide the input into
numbers and operation arrays or in fact
queues
and once we have those queues built up
then we pick up the first number
and we keep running this loop till the
numbers q is not empty
inside the while loop at each step we
pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator
and whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then
we
fetch the next
value in the numbers q and then we call
the get result based on the expression
and whatever result we get from the get
result we store it back into the rest
variable so we keep updating the rest
variable at every step
that's the reason
the result of 4 plus 5 gets stored in
the rest and next time you are calling
the get result for a multiply operation
here the rest value is 9 now and it says
9 into 3 again in the next time the rest
value will be updated to 27 because we
are storing the result back into the
result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error-free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts so in this
example we are going to have a look at a
calculator application
and this calculator application supports
primarily four different operations like
addition subtraction multiplication and
division so let's see how do we build
that app so in front of me right now is
open the main class so i have a main app
class here which has a public static
void main method
and the first thing we see is a read
input class which is calling a read
method so if you go to the read input
class it has a simple static method here
which is the read method and it is using
the scanner class if you remember i
talked about the scanner class which is
used to take inputs from the command
line from the user so we initialize the
scanner class and we start taking the
inputs and whatever the user inputs in
terms of the expression let's say the
user entered 4 plus 5 or whatever that
whole expression gets sent back into
this input line as a string and that
comes back here in that input expression
once we have captured the input
expression the next thing we do is
divide the input expression in the
numbers and the operators basically an
expression would be either something
like
4 plus 5
into 3
divided by 2 let's say let's say the
user entered this expression so this has
either numbers
or operators
so that's what we are doing here we are
using the split method of the string api
the string class basically and this
split method is going to split the
numbers and operators into two different
string arrays and here i am providing
the split expression that split at every
time you encounter one of these symbols
so this when you execute this particular
statement it is going to return a
numbers array which will be
created based on this expression so you
will get an array with 4 5 3 and 2
and similarly in the
operator array you are going to split or
pick out the elements every time you
receive a number so this operator array
is going to hold this plus sign this
multiply sign and this divide sign hope
you get the understanding that we are
just splitting the whole expression into
two different arrays where first array
is holding only the numbers and no
mathematical expressions and second
array is just holding the mathematical
operators and no numbers
and we'll see why we need to do that in
the upcoming lines
once i have created this string array i
just want to store or convert these
string arrays into a queue so i convert
this array into a list by calling the
array dot as list so this expression is
going to return a list
and then i'm going to convert this
normal list into a linked list and then
going to store this linked list into the
queue of numbers
and i'm going to do exactly the same
thing for the operator array as well
converting this into a generic list
converting that generic list into a
linked list
and then storing this link list as a
queue so i have an operators queue and i
have a numbers queue both of them have
been stored into a queue now and then
i'm using the poll method if you
remember the poll method of the queue is
used when you want to fetch the first
front element the head element of the
queue so whichever element is sitting at
the head of the queue will be taken out
the moment you call call the whole
method
so i fetch the first
number from the numbers q so in this
case 4 will be fetched here in this
variable and after that i run a loop on
the numbers q
and i'm going to run this
particular loop till this particular
queue is not empty if you see there's a
negation here so i'm going to pick up
numbers one by one from this numbers
queue till the number q becomes empty
and inside the loop i do this exact same
poll operation for the operations queue
so this operations queue is holding all
these mathematical operations
like plus star and divide so i'm going
to pick the head of it so in this case
plus will be picked up and will be
stored in this variable called opr
and then i am going to run a switch case
on this opr basically as i told you in
this particular calculator application
we are supporting four operations which
are addition subtraction multiplication
and division so i define a case for each
of the mathematical expression
so you see there are four different
cases here and for each case i'm
initializing a class if it's a plus sign
then i'm initializing the add class if
it's a minus sign then i'm initializing
the subtractors for multiplication i
have a class called multiply and for
division i have a class called divide
let's have a look at what these classes
are containing so if i go to the add
class first of all it is implementing an
interface called operate
and this operator interface has just a
single method called get results which
is accepting a variable argument array
if you remember i told you that you can
also use var arg array this is called a
arc expression this means that this
numbers will be an array of arbitrary
length it can be a one element array it
can be a two element array it can be a
four element array or whatever you
supply but it is still going to be a
fixed length array but the length is
going to be dependent upon how much
argument you supply to this particular
method so that is what this interface
operate is doing it just has one method
declared which is called get result
which is accepting an array of numbers
so
if the add class is implementing the
operator interface then it has to
override the get result method and here
it is just doing a summation of all the
numbers which have been supplied so if
you supply four numbers it is just going
to add up those four numbers and return
the sum
and the exact same kind of logic or
similar logic will be seen in other
operate classes so if i go to the
subtract class it runs the exact same
operation but it subtracts the values if
i go to the multiply class it is also
implementing the operate interface and
in the get result it is just multiplying
all the values similarly in the divide
class it is also implementing the
operator interface and it is dividing
all the numbers one by one so it's doing
pretty much the same thing in terms of
the expression and the logic the only
difference is whether you are using an
add operation or a subtract or multiply
or a divide
so we have checked all these classes and
the operator interface as well and let's
go back to the main app now now you also
see that i've defined a reference of
operate here and each of the switch case
block i'm assigning the object type to
this interface reference so i'm using
the concept of dynamic binding which we
talked about when we talked about
interfaces that we can also do dynamic
binding where we can assign an object
to an interface type and the object type
will depend upon the expression so once
we have filled that based on the case
while filtering out this expression and
picking up plus star and divide
sequentially then we go to the next line
of outside the switch case block which
is to pick the next number from the
queue remember we already did one poll
here so as per this example 4 was here
in this res
and now when we do this number dot poll
again
5 will be picked up because that will be
the next head of the queue so we pick up
five here and then we call operate dot
get result now this get result will be
called based on the expression which was
encountered first in the queue again
looking at the example the first
expression encountered will be plus
so the expression was plus so the
operate type object is of add type
and when you call operate dot get result
the get result method of add class is
going to get invoked and it is going to
sum four and five this rest is holding
four right now based on what i described
here numbers.poll
and this num is holding the
the second operand basically basically
five here so 4 plus 5 gets evaluated
here in this case and then it again goes
back here and it checks if the number q
is now empty no it is still not empty
because we still have 3 n2 left there so
again it does the operations pole and it
picks up multiply sign here
then it again runs the switch case since
it's a multiply sign it will go here and
it will initialize the operate interface
reference as the object of multiply
class then coming here it will do a
numbers dot poll and this time the
numbers dot poll is going to pick up 3
so 3 will be picked up here and then the
current value of result which is already
9 4 plus 5 was 9 the current value of
result will be updated here so rest will
be 9 here and num will be 3 here and
when you call operate dot get result the
multiply classes get result will get
called and it will say 9 into 3 which
will become 27 it will again go back
here to this particular line and it will
check again if the numbers queue is now
empty no it is still not empty because
we still have one element left
then it pulls
uh the queue of the operations where the
expression divide is present there which
is the only element left in this
particular operations queue and since we
have the opr value as divide this case
block gets called and the new divide
class gets initialized the divide class
basically gets initialized and we come
here and we do numbers.poll now the last
number which is available in this queue
is 2 which gets picked up here
and then we again call
operate.getresult this time since the
operate object refer object operator
reference type was of divide class type
so when we call operate.getresult the
divide operation or the getresult method
of the divide class basically this
method will get invoked and it will
divide the current value of result which
was 4 plus 5 9 into 3 which was 27 so it
is going to divide 27 by 2 which was the
last value of the numbers dot poll so it
is it is going to execute 27 by 2 and
whatever value it gets it is going to
store the
value back into the rest variable and
then it is again going to go back here
and again going to check the condition
if the numbers q is not empty but now
the numbers queue is empty because 2 was
the last element so it is going to come
out of the loop and it is going to print
the final result that is how this whole
program is working now let's try to see
this in action and will try to execute
the exact same expression
so if i right click and go to run as and
run this as java application
and i supply an expression saying 4 plus
5
star
3 divide 2
and if i now hit enter i get the value
as 13.5 which is exactly what we ran
through because 4 plus 5 will be
evaluated first which will result into 9
then 9 into 3 will be 27 and 27 divided
by 2 will be 13.5 exactly so this is how
this whole program is running where we
first take the inputs and then we divide
the input into numbers and operation
arrays or in fact queues and once we
have those queues built up then we pick
up the first number and we keep running
this loop till the numbers q is not
empty inside the while loop at each step
we pick up the first expression or the
operator we check what is the operator
whether it is an addition subtraction
multiplication or division operator and
whatever kind of operator we have we
initialize the corresponding class of it
and then we
fetch the next value in the numbers q
and then we call the get result based on
the expression and whatever result we
get from the get result we store it back
into the rest variable so we keep
updating the rest variable at every step
that's the reason the result of 4 plus 5
gets stored in the rest and next time
you are calling the get result for a
multiply operation here the rest value
is 9 now and it says 9 into 3 again in
the next time the rest value will be
updated to 27 because we are storing the
result back into the result variable
so this is all i want to cover in this
particular session where we looked at an
example of a calculator application
purely from the console standpoint
obviously there can be lot more stuff
which we can do into this particular
application make it more error-free and
cover a lot of corner cases like
validating the inputs etc also
looking at or putting some conditions
around the exception handling handling
the divide by zero scenario etc which is
not here but this is just to show you
the basic idea of how you can build
simple to complex cli applications using
the core java concepts let's get started
with spring boot and how we can build a
simple application using spring boot
before we go further let's understand
why we need spring boot and the basic
idea of spring boot is to build restful
web services if you want to know more
about what are restful services please
you can read about the restful concept
as a concept what does rest stand for
but the basic idea is that if you are
accessing anything over http then that
particular component can be built as a
restful component and spring boot is the
most popular choice for building restful
web services today and even in fact
micro services which you might have
heard about so you can build micro
services which also run on https using
spring boot so what i'm showing you
right now is the official guide of
spring which you can use to build an
application with spring boot it will
list down all the requisites which you
need in terms of the uh jdk
installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same springs initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dye my
life template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or whatnot what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar this pom.xml here which
will provide all the list of jars and
dependencies which are required for this
particular project so you can see all
the dependencies here pretty much the
similar ones we have a starter web we
have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and introductory session so
we will keep the logics to minimum and
i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
we get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application.class with
any command line arguments which you
might want to use once you do this it is
going to return an application context
object to you and the application
context object can be used to get all
the bean definitions by calling this
method which says get bean definition
names so that's the basic logic which is
being run in the main class now we also
have a controller but this time it's not
a web controller but it's a rest
controller so you see in the previous
example we just had written something
like this it was just a pure controller
but here we have become more specific we
are saying that hey this is not a simple
mvc controller but this is a spring boot
controller or technically a rest
controller so spring provides a separate
annotation for that which is at the rate
rest controller so you write that
particular annotation or that on the top
of the controller class which you are
creating and then you provide a request
mapping similar to what we did in spring
mvc but while you return it you do not
return a view technology you just return
the raw response here i'm just returning
a string but you can return a json
object you can return an xml object or
whatever you want to but not a view
technology that's what i'm doing like
like you can see there's literally
nothing i'm doing in this it's just a
simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
bom.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a pom.xml
available here and all the code direct
is also available here so now i will
just run this application and to run
this application i'm just going to type
mvn spring hyphen boot colon run and hit
enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started and
let's go back to uh the controller and
actually the main app main endpoint and
see what we were doing there i did a cis
out here which said let's inspect the
beans provided by spring boot and then i
was printing all the bean names and if i
go back to the output i will see the
same line being written here which was
around let's inspect the beans so you
can see that message which says let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot and then all the beans which are
available in the application context are
printed here so that's that's the basic
idea which i want to give you that you
can actually build a spring boot
application and you can write your rest
controllers return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your application for from the web
browser as well so let's try to hit that
particular url which i wrote here so the
url of hello
so for that let me just open a new
cognito window and our application is
already running so if i just say http
localhost 8080. slash i get this message
here which says greetings from spring
boot and this is the message which we
were sending from the rest controller so
this validates our understanding that we
can invoke a rest controller which is a
spring boot rest controller via the same
method but this time we are not getting
an html but we are just returning this
particular string now you can use the
string in any ways you want so it
depends upon the consumer so that's all
i want to cover as part of the spring
boot now spring boot is a huge huge
topic and we can spend hours and hours
talking about spring boot but since this
is more of an introductory session so i
just wanted the concept to get
introduced and remember the value
proposition of why you would need spring
boot the basic idea is to build restful
web services or build restful micro
services that's the basic idea behind
using spring boot in your applications
and also remember the difference between
web mvc spring mvc application and
spring boot application spring mvc is
for building web application spring boot
is for building restful applications
which might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment
let's get started with our demo of a
project which is using spring boot to
build a restful web service so a restful
web service is nothing but any end point
which you can access or you can consume
the data from via an http layer or via a
simply a web layer because most of the
web traffic which we deal with is built
on http so to take an example if you go
to any website where you sometimes see
on the top right corner you see today's
weather so how is that today's weather
coming in it's coming in via a rest web
service the website which you are
accessing is basically hitting an http
endpoint uh which is uh where the where
the weather application is sitting and
it asks for the weather data and the
rest web application just returns the
data and that's how the website is able
to show you the current weather so
restful web services are everywhere and
they are the most popular way to build
applications today where you just build
your restful web service and you expose
an http url and then the consumers need
to just access that http url to consume
the data from your application and you
see this makes it very easy because
there is no data type restrictions there
is no tight coupling here it's just an
http endpoint so that's the basic idea
and we will look at a project where we
will be using spring boot to build a
restful web service and then we will try
to run that web service to save some
data and also to return some data so
here on the on the package explorer you
see i have created a project called rest
service and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project
needs some dependencies some jars to
execute it for example spring itself is
basically a jar so you need to include
the spring jar in your project so that
your project can become a spring project
and there are generally two dependency
tools one is maven and one is gradle in
this particular project i am using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called pom.xml.xml
if it's a gradle project you will see a
dot gradle file that's how you can spot
whether the project is using maven for
dependency management or it is using
gradle for dependency management so
let's open the pom.xml since it's an xml
file it will be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
board projects have this as a parent as
a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the package name how do you want
to see the jar name on what is the
actual name what is the jar version etc
etc you also set the minimum required
java version to run this application and
then you in the dependency sections you
provide all the jars which you need to
run your project successfully both
compile and run your project
successfully so we added the spring boot
starter web on dependency which
basically brings all the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository count context component scan
all the interesting features which
spring provides get wrapped up inside
the spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is via using the
spring boot data jpa library we will see
this how this library can be used but
basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an in
memory h2 database so i'm not using an
external database like mysql or oracle
or post resql because that will just
make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a string boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
spring boot can run this project that's
all i have in the palm dot xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create
any any name with the class and then you
add a public static void main method
inside the public static void main
method you call spring application
dot run and this run method is basically
going to run your application and you
just provide the same class name which
you just wrote here so you just say dot
class and if you're supplying any
command line arguments it can interpret
that command line arguments as well if
you want so you would always need an
entry point in an application and this
is the entry point which spring boot
supports and this is if you see this
code this is just normal code to make
spring be aware about this class being
treated as an entry point you need to
add add the red spring boot application
annotation on top of the class this is
one of the annotation which is coming
directly from the spring boot library
you can see this import so once you add
this
then only spring will be able to treat
this class as an entry point otherwise
spring doesn't know where to start from
so when you run spring it will it will
try to find a class with an annotation
spring boot application
and then inside the class it will try to
find a public start a static void main
method and once it has found both of
them then it will just run the
application so it's very simple nothing
fancy here and what we are dealing with
here is a student object so we will try
to insert a student object and we will
try to retrieve the student object so
if you ignore these annotations which
i've added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grade
application you would like to keep your
objects immutable means once they have
been created you would not like somebody
to allow to change the values of the
object this just makes programming but
much more easy if you treat all the
objects in your application as immutable
that's why i have not added setters here
it's just considered a good practice so
apart from the standard things which we
have already seen there are two things
here which i want to talk about let's
first talk about this one so aggregate
entity is the annotation which is coming
from java x persistent entity
persistence entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable spring boot
will automatically
generate a new id value every time you
create a new student object and how does
it generate you you can provide the
generation type as well so currently
i've just said that set it as automatic
but you can set it as identity sequence
or written or controlled by table you
can also see the explanation of each of
these here but i've just kept it as auto
which basically
let the persistence provider pick any
appropriate strategy for the particular
database in our case the database is h2
so that's about the entity class let's
call this as entity class now let's move
to the repository so you need a
repository class like i explained in
dots in that three tier architecture you
always need a dow layer or a repository
layer to store your student object into
the database so we have enabled the
student object to be saved but we need a
handler which can save this particular
file this particular object into the
database and the repository classes are
the classes which will allow you to do
that so you create a very simple
interface you what you name whatever you
want to name your interface as and then
you say extends jpa repository the type
of the object and the unique identifier
of the object so the type of the object
is student here and the unique
identifier of the student object is the
id which is of type long so you need to
just supply the types type of the object
type of the primary key or the type of
the unique identifier and this
annotation is coming from spring boot
you can see specifically spring boot
data library which we added so you just
need to create an interface extend it
from jp repository and make sure that
you add this annotation as well spring
heavily uses the concept of annotations
and this will help spring understand
that this is a repository layer class
and it will apply some more metadata to
this class while this class is running
in the jvm so what happens here you just
created an interface you did not provide
any method to create or any method to
delete or any method to get a student
object because all of that is
automatically provided by springboot via
the jpa repository class if we go inside
this class and if you scroll down you'll
see the find all method find all find
all by id save all flush save and flush
delete etc and if you go further up this
also extends the paging and sorting
repository which provides pagination and
sorting facilities but the interesting
one is that pagings and sorting
repository again extends a crud
repository and if you go to the crud
repository you will find all the basic
methods to save an entity save multiple
entities find an entity by the id that's
why it needed that long type to make
sure this that it can execute this
method you can check the existence of an
object find all the entries find all by
id count them delete them so all the
basic crud functionality so we call them
as crud because the reason it is called
crud because create read update delete
that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this
thread repository provides all the
methods and their implementations
automatically we do not need to write
any code at all so that's why spring
boot is so awesome and that's why
springboard is very popular because it's
zero code in the repository and you
still get all the crud functionality so
that's about repository now we have
covered the entity class we have covered
the repository class we have covered the
entry point class now the only thing
which is remaining is the is the
endpoint the http endpoint which i
talked about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put
add the rate rest controller annotation
on top of it this annotation will allow
string to treat this particular class as
an endpoint class then you can auto wire
the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at run time student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the
autobot annotation and will
automatically supply an object whenever
it is required then i have two methods
here since we are talking about http
endpoints so i have represented a post
method here and a get method here the
way you will write a post method is via
the ratepost mapping annotation and then
you can provide the url path on which
somebody should call your endpoint to
save something so for example somebody
can call it http localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
these students uh and with their id and
then you can pick a particular student's
id supply that student id value here
dynamically that's why at the curly
braces curly braces supports dynamic
value so here it can insert one two
three or whatever the student id you
want to fetch the value for you provide
that value in the student slash id and
all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
8080
student slash one then student with the
id 1 will be returned from the request
and you need to put advert get mapping
to make sure that this method is treated
as an http get method and you can
provide the type you can say get student
and here this dynamic value
is captured with the add the rate path
variable because you need to know the id
right whatever id somebody has supplied
it in the url you need to capture that
ide and then use that ide for calling
the repository so that's you can do that
by using the advert path variable so
here i'm just saying whatever id is
coming in i will store that value inside
this ide once i've done that then i can
again call student repository dot find
by id which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it's a just a
types of defensive programming style so
this will return an optional and you can
call a get method to return the actual
student object this will return an
optional of student so option of student
means that this optional object may have
a student or may not have a student why
did spring do that because the id
somebody is supplying that id can be
invalid also right so optional object
takes care of that that if there is no
student found then you will not get a
null pointer exception and if there is a
student found you can return that so
it's just a defensive programming style
which spring has adopted by returning an
optional of the student object rather
than directly the student object but if
you're confident that this particular
option of student object does contain a
student object then just call
optional.get which i've called here
which will return the actual student
object sitting inside the optional
object you can read more about the
optional object and its usage from the
official java docs and there are tons of
examples available on it on internet so
this is about the controller we have
covered all the classes now it's time to
run the application so you go to the
command prompt you go to the particular
file folder location and there you just
say mvn spring hyphen boot colon run so
i just hit enter and this is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
risk client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically uh
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name page and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i'm sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created so everything
is good here my object has been stored
here and now it's time to fetch the
object so it has already been saved into
the h2 in memory database and you can
obviously go and connect to the in
memory h2 database and have a look at it
but for simplicity i'm just gonna do
this here and let's say the first object
is generally
added as the id 1 by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student slash id url and it is
going to find the database with that id
and if it finds a student object with
that id it is going to return that so
lets confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it's going to
hit a get request with this particular
url springboard is going to find if a
student with the id 1 exists in its
database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with two now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the string application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was 1 so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id you
are going to get a 500 internal server
error and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add find all method you
can add update student method you can
add a delete student method you can have
all different kinds of filters like for
example return to me all the students
starting with the name a or return all
the first students with the role number
one and hundred or between 100 so you
can write as many endpoints as you want
and build this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want now with that we
have come to an end of this exciting
session on java projects for 2022. i
hope you had a wonderful and interesting
session and if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources that we have used in this
session then please feel free to let us
know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you